all right it is time for drew's news
your fresh and fluffy news waffle
covered in that gooey good news syrup
and with me at the desk is the sweetest
man in town rossi ross matthews
[Applause]
i know i know sometimes like i i want it
really savory so i like a lot of butter
oh please yeah you know what the butter
gets in the little oh let go my eggo
girl that's mine i know russia what day
is it today it's pop quiz hey
yes
pay attention one member of our city
audience is gonna be put to the test
we're gonna ask you or you three
questions about today's show and if you
get it right you're gonna take home a
thousand dollars yes so get out here
whatever it takes
um sometimes i like to picture like a
little spiral notebook and a number two
pencil just a metaphor of the mind in
your mind yeah just be taking notes all
day well i'm very excited about this
first story um okay so check this out
you guys there is a fascinating new
documentary headed to netflix on april
27th and we have got an exclusive first
look the evening standard reports that
the mystery of marilyn monroe the
unheard tapes will explore maryland's
final days and uncover new
information and they are using
previously unheard audio recordings from
people who knew her well so take a
listen and look
to get people with information about the
night marilyn died it was difficult let
it be
i can't say anything and i knew it all i
did what you always have to do if you
meet a dead end
i went back to the beginning
[Music]
okay
obsessed already
i mean completely well and then later
this year netflix is also releasing
their highly anticipated biopic blonde
with anna diamous and she's playing
marilyn
and the movie just got some headlines
because it got an nc 17 rating hi
i really wanted to watch it before and
now i'm like i can't wait to watch it
well i have to say i read the director's
quote uh in reaction to the kerfuffle of
people going nc-17 and he said and i
quote if the audience doesn't like it
that's the freaking audience's problem
i'm not running for public office
okay
and yet i'm like oh in these days you
can rub for public office right don't
you worry about that
um i am so excited what does
sort of intrigue me about the marylands
and the elvises is
does it always have to get so tragic
do we
love that about them do they have to
reach those points is there anyone that
we sort of accolade that is a healthy
human being i don't know but these
figures they just are larger than life
and i i want to kind of understand how
they felt and what they went through and
what is it like to be that adored
clearly it's not an easy space to live
in yeah and with these tapes of her
maybe we'll get some of those answers
yes yes yeah
[Music]